AOC
has a brutal accusation for republicans
which is that we run our mouths about
the immigration problem all the time
but we don't have any solutions
I didn't hear in your testimony the
alternative sites you've advocated for
could you remind me of which those are
well
in the conversation as we know as we I'm
sorry I only have 18 seconds which are
the sites that you propose as an
alternative
I don't have a proposal so you don't
have a proposal alternative
no proposed alternative
no Solutions here no ideas here but
Democrats we're authorizing 500 000 work
permits so people can get on their feet
and support themselves Democrats were
proposing comprehensive immigration
reform Democrats were talking about
saying let's reassess our foreign
policies so that people aren't fleeing
you know making sure that we aren't
participating in the destabilization of
what's Happening abroad and all I'm
hearing right now is that we're not
being met in the middle no support no
path to citizenship no identified
Alternatives just grievances we need to
get it together
and make sure that we're getting on the
right page and if the ideas being
presented here in this community are
being disagreed with I'd like to see
some actual functional Alternatives that
Center and preserve the Dignity of both
people who are coming here to fulfill an
American Dream and the American citizens
here who want to support them
that was a whole lot of words
without any particular solutions that I
heard from AOC either so this is her
clip AOC she's taken a page out of the
daily wire facts and logic Clips where
she's got the the Fast Cuts and it goes
on to the speaker and onto the
questioner and then she gets the nice
60-second Zinger out there pioneered by
Young America's foundation and other
right-wing groups and she's flipping and
she said you have no Solutions you have
no Solutions and then she babbles and
blathers for 60 seconds
without offering any solutions herself
the accusation isn't even legitimate
Republicans have very clear Solutions
here is my solution I got two of them
for immigration
we should restrict immigration
and we should expand deportations
I solved it do I get a prize from AOC I
did it
we should restrict it
we should restrict all immigration
obviously illegal immigration but also
legal immigration because we have way
too many people coming into the country
and it's no knock on the people but the
movement of foreigners into the United
States over the last 65 years is the
largest movement of human beings ever in
recorded history and it's led to social
breakdown because there's there's no
longer a coherent cohesive Society so we
got to slow that down drastically I'm
not saying we totally seal up the border
and don't let a single human being in
I don't think that's practicable I don't
think but we could drastically reduce
all immigration illegal and legal
immigration
and we could do it pretty easily we've
done it before in American history and
then what about deportations am I saying
we're going to deport every single
illegal that's in the United States no I
don't think it's practical I don't think
most people would want it it's not going
to happen
but we could drastically expand
deportations you've got criminals now
who who go around who kill people who
sell drugs who who sell flesh or pimps
who are working for the cartels and then
they get arrested and they get let off
the hook
so we could just
reduce the threshold for which someone
is deported drastically that would
drastically increase the deportations
while not going after you know the the
really sweet innocent little person
who's just following uh his or her
lights who doesn't commit all that many
crimes other than the crime of entering
the country illegally and the kind of
person who most Americans don't want to
see deported okay they're going to be at
the bottom of the deportation list so
it's probably not going to happen
but why can't we do that why can't we
just directionally enforce laws that are
already on the books and drastically
restrict immigration and drastically
expand deportation that seems simple
that's my solution
yet they won't do it the Democrat AOC is
not going to do that she wants to open
the Border completely and flood the
country with foreigners but the
Republicans don't want to do it either
the Chamber of Commerce Republicans
don't want to do it but don't tell me we
don't have Solutions I got a simple
solution we've used it many times in
American history and it worked out great
and now that we're not following my
solution things are not working out so
great right now go to hallow.com Knowles
there is no better time to build a daily
habit of prayer and meditation building
a habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being also you owe prayer to the
Lord your God so you need to pray hallow
is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the United States it has helped
countless people maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you too download
the app for free at hallow.com Knowles
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress all along the way not sure
where to start check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year my favorite
podcast available on the Hello app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with Halo you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using Halo
to connect with others who share your
beliefs and values can provide a sense
of belonging support and Foster a sense
of community and you will learn to be a
better person in today's broken world
right now go to hallow.com try three
months for free hello.com Knowles now
there's another debate that's going to
take place not with the primary
contestants yet that that one will be in
a little bit the next debate coming up
is going to be between the California
governor Patrick Bateman
doing business as Gavin Newsom and
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and
Newsome is already trash talking to
santis a month out from the debate why
are you doing that and what is your
strategy well it's I don't know if
that's the right question why is he
doing it is the right question he's
running I think I'm not sure after
tonight but currently he's running for
president United States uh do you think
he's still going to be you think he'll
still be a candidate November 30th
that's an open-ended question part of me
wonders if you know the fact that he
took this debate the fact that he took
the bait in relation to this debate so
as he's completely unqualified to be
president United States that's my humble
person why is that you're baiting him
with the debate offer I mean why is he
debating a guy he's not even running for
president when he's running for
president he's showing up at the Reagan
Library hollowed ground and he puts out
an ad today not for his presidential
campaign to promote a debate against the
governor of California I mean this guy's
distracted so I don't know that he has
it in his heart I think here's my
personal opinion about Ron DeSantis he
regrets running for president he made a
huge mistake
so he keeps going on like this just
taunting DeSantis and
it reminds me of a WWE match
or even in an actual sport that isn't
just show business like a boxing match
when they're when they're trash talking
before boxing you know this guy I'm
gonna wipe the floor with in this case a
complete joke he you know my I think he
regrets running he's a he's unfocused
he's undisciplined he's just mocking him
relentlessly uh this too
is a sideshow I mean that unfortunately
that's the point that Gavin Newsom is
right about is that this debate probably
will not determine
the 2024 presidential race the thing
that he's being dishonest about here is
that he's not running for president
Gavin Newsom is obviously trying to run
for president he's not willing to put
himself up against Joe Biden because he
thinks that then Biden would grind him
up in the way that Donald Trump is
attacking Ron DeSantis right now but he
obviously wants to run for president and
this DeSantis versus Newsom debate is
the undercard debate if Joe Biden's
Marionette strings collapse and you know
he falls to the ground or if Donald
Trump is uh sent to Elba or Saint Helena
and and uh or or he's you know taken out
with the Hillary special then there will
be an opening and and Santa's perhaps
can fill that Gap but as of now even
that and I think that could be a
substantive debate about two different
Visions for America you want America to
be like California do you want America
to be like Florida which way are the
U-Haul trucks moving I think it could be
a great substantive debate but once
again don't shoot the messenger here
folks I'm just the one who has to see
things clearly pass the event through to
the election I don't see
how this moves
the needle boy what a great clip that
was now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles show
channel we'll see you next time